well when you have children i think most
parents they
think about the future of their children
and
what talents they may
might have and what opportunities they
might see and
we were looking for traits in our
children
something special
etc but
in our estimation they were quite
normally very lovable wonderful children
and
the only thing maybe slightly special
was that magnus at an early age seemed
to have the ability to focus
for hours at a time at specific tasks
whether it was uh doing
puzzles
at the age of one and two or
learning all the color brands and all
the countries in the world all the flags
all the populations etc
so that
by the time he was four
again we thought they were normal
children
normal possibilities but at the same
time i thought maybe chess might be
something for him specifically
and i tried to teach him and his elder
sister ellen who was six at the time
the rules of chess and
we played a little bit although
of course they are beginners and
typically when they learn how to move
the pieces we played just
i had
my king and one pawn and they had all
their pieces and they would try to mate
me
well and
it was typically an autumn activity for
a couple of years and
i think i concluded after a year or two
basically oh okay it's it's it's a bit
fun but
uh they're quite interested but they're
not kind of
[Music]
clinging on to to this so
maybe chess is not something for them
after all and how could i be so wrong
so but fortunately the good thing was
that
by the time magnussen started
to learn chess
seriously and
because he started to study on his own
about three years later just before he
turned eight
sitting by the chessboard a lot
by then
it was his own
drive and
interest and ambition kind of yeah
coming through while i didn't have
ambitions on his behalf